[Music]
Disney Princesses lived once upon a time
in a land far far away so there are not
a lot of things that we can relate to
but what if they lived in the 21st
century and that we had the chance to
meet them in college their story would
be really different just wait until you
see Pocahontas new passion if you love
Disney Princesses as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe to our channel and
like this video for more stories like
this today we are showing you ten Disney
Princesses reimagined as college
students Belle she is probably the
princess who would like the most to go
to college the bookworm always loved to
read and this is why people thought that
she was a bit strange even though there
were not a lot of books in her village
Belle kept reading the same stories over
and over again which made her love them
even more she was lucky to meet a man or
we should say a beast who loved reading
just as much as her and when she had the
chance to enter his library she knew
that this is where she wanted to spend
the rest of her life she used books as a
way to escape to that new world and this
is how she realized that she wasn't
trapped anymore we think that if she
lived in the 21st century Belle would be
a real geek she would fall in love with
every character that she meets and be
part of every fandom as we can see the
bookworm is now captivated by the world
of superheroes and Batman is her
favorite she is probably studying
literature to one day write her own
books and we would love to be the first
to read it will she talk about how she
met the Beast we think that this book
will quickly be turned into a movie
Aurora this princess realized every
college students dream sleeping all the
time when she was only a baby the fairy
godmothers gave her the gifts of beauty
and
and then the evil fairy Maleficent
appeared jealous of not being invited
she cursed the little child this is why
as soon as she turned 16 years old
Aurora pricked her finger on a spinning
wheel and fell into a deep sleep the
fairy godmother saved her from a
terrible fate when she was young but she
still won't open her eyes until she is
saved by a kiss of true love from a
prince her beauty was enough for Phillip
to do everything to save her and they
lived happily ever after
we have to admit that we are a little
bit jealous we would love to spend our
college years sleeping all the time
until the love of our life is here to
wake us up when things be much easier we
think so
Paul Westover for college humor
reimagined Aurora as a young woman who
was always late to class because she
never wakes up in the morning her
teachers are used to seeing her arrive
late to class but she always has a good
excuse she is the only one who can say
that she has been cursed when she was
still a baby
snow-white she was the youngest Disney
Princess
so it seems like she skipped a couple of
years in school to get there and we
understand why life wasn't easy for Snow
White
her stepmother was jealous of her beauty
so she dressed her up in rags and forced
her to work as a servant this is how the
young princess learned many things like
how to clean the house cook delicious
food and wash the dishes this is
something we wish we learned in high
school before going to college and this
is also what saved Snow White when she
offered to work for the Seven Dwarfs in
exchange for a place to stay we bet that
her prince was also happy to see that
this young woman was already really
independent the princess has always been
a hard worker and now she doesn't want
to be the fairest of them all but the
smartest no matter what time of the day
it is you can see Snow White studying to
get the best grades young eighty-six
reimagine as a simple girl who loves to
sing in the school choir during her free
time she is working on her computer and
she loves Apple products having the
chance to take care of her appearance
doesn't hurt either we can say that this
young woman
got the beauty and the brain mulan after
working as a soldier we can say that
this girl is ready for anything but
going to college is not going to be as
easy as she might think
Malone's family expected her to marry a
man and become a housewife but when it
was time for her to show what she could
do we understood that this was clearly
not the place for her the young woman
decided to break the rules instead and
dressed up as a man to join the army
things weren't easy there either
but at least she had the motivation to
work hard because she knew that she was
doing something important and this is
how she defeated all odds and became a
true hero after going to a private
school for boys only Mulan finally has
the opportunity to be whoever she wants
to be in college she still loves
dressing up but she doesn't have to hide
who she is
as Paul Westover for college humor
reimagined her it's hard to feel like
you don't fit in but this college
student doesn't care about being popular
the only thing that's important for her
is the love for herself and Mulan knows
that no one can take it away from her
and we think that li Shang will love
this idea too because he won't be able
to keep himself from falling in love
with this unique woman Tiana
the young girl always wanted to open her
restaurant with her father he told her
that wishing was one thing but she also
had to work hard when he passed away
Tiana knew that she would have to work
harder than ever to make her dreams come
true working as a waitress she did her
best to save the money she needed to
start her own business but a man or we
should say a frog decided to make things
much more complicated everyone was happy
at the end but we still can't believe
Tiana had to go through this to open her
restaurant not a lot of people can do
that and we think that in college Tiana
will be stronger than ever she is not
only studying to become the greatest
cook but she is also working part-time
during the weekend
if this girl has one thing on her mind
you can be sure that nothing will stop
her not even the fact that there are
only 24 hours in a day however there is
one thing that can be a major
distraction for tea
as Renzo Ferreira imagined her she just
loves boys and wants to make sure that
she gets their attention if her father
wouldn't approve then naveen's no good
for her
Kiana should focus on school if she
really wants to open her own restaurant
any time soon Moana if there is one
thing that has always fascinated this
young girl it is the ocean she always
wanted to travel the sea even if her
parents kept stopping her from realizing
her dream but what she didn't know was
that she was actually the only one who
had the power to save her tribe and when
she learned about this she was
courageous enough to leave on her own on
a boat to meet the demigod Maui it
wasn't only a quest to find the mystical
heart that was stolen but also for Moana
to find out who she truly was even if
things were difficult and that she
wanted to give up the young woman
finally realized that there was a reason
why she was chosen and she came back to
save the world in the 21st century mo
Anna's parents probably weren't happy to
learn that she wanted to leave the tribe
to go to college but she did it anyway
and is now studying theology as young
sixty-eight reimagined her lawanna loves
mythology legends and fables
and wants to one day become the hero of
her own story it is not easy for her to
be separated from her family for such a
long time but she knows that it is going
to be worth it in the end
she is now where she is meant to be
Ariel The Little Mermaid always wanted
to leave the sea to live on the land and
meeting the love of her life was the
last thing she needed to make that big
step after saving Prince Erik she knew
that she needed to meet this man again
this is why she decided to give away her
voice in exchange for a pair of legs
let's remember that she didn't even know
anything about that guy at that time it
wasn't easy to get used to this new
world without being able to communicate
and it didn't help when Ursula decided
to take her place next to Erik but the
Prince finally recognized who the
love of his life truly was and the two
ended up happily ever after in college
Arielle still can't help falling in love
over and over again even if she is
studying marine biology she can't resist
the temptation to look at this handsome
guy in European history class she is
ready to do anything for him including
changing program to make sure that they
are both in the same class don't do that
girl that's not a good idea no boy is
ever worth changing who you truly are
but that is something that everyone is
going to live in college and you have to
make mistakes to learn from them
Jasmin she was probably the luckiest
Disney princess but living in a palace
wasn't enough for her Jasmine didn't
want to live a beautiful life she just
wanted to live for real no one was going
to tell her what to do and certainly not
who she was supposed to marry this is
why she decided to escape to see what
the world outside of her palace looked
like she then met Aladdin and the two
immediately fell in love with each other
he gave her the chance to escape on a
magic carpet and discovering this whole
new world was all this girl ever wanted
no need to make three wishes when you
can only make one stay together forever
in college jasmine is still the kind of
girl who wants to be a little wild
after years of homeschooling she is
finally living far away from her father
and she has the chance to do whatever
she wants when you look at how Renzo
Ferrer reimagined her this girl looks
ready to go to a music festival and we
know that a lot of weird things are
happening there this girl is still young
so it is the best time to make these
kinds of experiences it's by going out
of your comfort zone that you can find
who you are and maybe even find love
Rapunzel this girl spent almost 18 years
trapped in a tower so she knows how to
keep herself busy she woke up at 7 in
the morning
cleaned her room and read two or three
books then it was time for her daily
activities like playing guitar cooking
dancing and brushing her hair but what
she loved the most was painting all over
her room like a Windows that gave her
the
to see what the outside world looked
like and then she did the same thing
every day all over again it must have
been really hard for her to live alone
in this tower but she did more things in
one day than what we can do in a week
this is why we bet that when Rapunzel
goes to college she will be part of
every club and participate in all the
activities we don't know if it is part
of her magic power but this girl just
finds a way to beat everywhere at the
same time young 86 reimagined Rapunzel
as a girl who loves everything she is
studying fashion and design and when she
is not at school
you can still see her drawing sewing
sculpting and crafting we just hope that
she has some time left to have a social
life because we would love to become her
best friend
Pocahontas as a Native American nature
was her school and grandmother willow
was her teacher with her friends the
raccoon and the hummingbirds the
daughter of the chief came to visit the
willow tree and this is when she found
out that the English were arriving when
they came to visit her home they thought
that they were more civilized than the
people who had been living in America
during all this time but Pocahontas was
actually the one who had to teach them
something instead of destroying the land
she told John Smith about the beauty of
nature and this is how they bonded
fascinated by each others worlds
unfortunately the two friends ended up
being separated and we think that it was
better this way but what if this story
happened centuries after this time the
Native American princess uses something
else to show others how she sees the
world
Renzo Ferrer reimagined her as a
photographer and she is cooler than ever
Pocahontas will never forget her origins
and this is why she loves taking
pictures of the world around her to make
the memories last forever there are so
many things that you can learn when you
understand how other people think which
Disney princess would be your best
friend in college don't be shy to answer
in the comments section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for 10 Disney Princesses reimagined
as college
if you want to see more stories like
this make sure to watch 10 Disney movies
reimagined in the modern day thanks for
watching
[Music]